foreign
what do you guys think of uh Brendan
Frazier in the whale I didn't see it I
know it's really good oh what do you
think of Brandon Frazier in the whale in
this photo though I think it sucks that
he didn't actually put on the weight
yeah right fake Christian Bale would
have [__] ate birthday cakes every
single day I think it's like a Star Wars
adaptation
Jabba the man yeah he looks like Java so
he actually did try to put on weight but
it wasn't enough weight he he actually
sucks Christian Bale would have done it
so they is that a fat suit or is it like
a uh
oh it looks like CG so um basically that
movie won awards for the work that they
did to make it so realistic yeah so what
he did was he wanted to make sure that
uh at least um for on Brendan's uh side
he said he wanted a fat suit that
actually was
um
it was accurate to gravity because all
the other fat suits in like Nutty
Professor whatever they're not they're
just like kind of a joke but he's like
it has to look like and feel and move
the same way like an actual person would
and it was really important for him to
do that because he was like I'm
representing this thing but uh the soap
brand dove
has expressed that they are upset at how
they didn't just cast a fat actor get
the [__] out
[__] kidding me brands are trying to
[__] cancel that
why the [__] does Dove soap give a [__]
because that's their thing remember how
like Dove is all like body uh body
positivity oh I didn't know that yeah
about selling [__] soap
remember back in the day when Dove had
that billboard or that commercial and
that billboard that had just like women
with like regular realistic bodies and
it wasn't model oh my God that was dumb
and it had like eight women in a row
like they were all just from White and
it was like kind of like a big deal
because they were like wow they're just
were they the first certainly I don't
know they were the first they may have
been the loudest you know what I liked
about it is like that billboard doesn't
catch your eye and you don't you don't
even look at it
because I hate advertising wait how how
much in the movie The Whale how big was
he supposed to be responsible company
500 one moment Nick
exactly hey how many hair follicles on
the [__] outfit huh what shirt does
he wear in the first time it says 650
650 pounds is it human hair or is it
should reach that no I don't know but he
did put on weight though he did put from
it yeah but uh they wanted it to be like
like major major okay so which actor
who's 600 pounds is gonna play that role
you tell me I'm telling you which 600
pound actor Darren Day Lewis would eat
ribs every hour on the hour until he's
[__] ready he's committed yeah
Brandon Frazier I think he's a little
bit of a hack job I know you're talking
[__] about the guy from The Mummy dude I
like him but I think that yeah I think
this is a coffee it's a cop up but he's
not committed so Dove Dove tweeted stop
giving fat suits Awards we want better
representation in Hollywood oh my God
let a fat man play a fat man that's the
new stick we debate that like let me let
me just make sure that everybody knows
um as much as Dove takes the stance of
like body positive like all women all
bodies blah blah they make bottles in
different like shapes yeah they do they
do they got this thing just remember
that
um they are trying to sell so because
Dove's parent company's Unilever which
also owns ax body spray and
um and another skin product for uh
pigment lightening interesting so they
are not what you think like the parent
company why are companies trying to
embody like being a human being I think
because like when you look at Unilever
right they have their different uh
companies and they're like okay this one
lean towards this marketing yeah that
one lean towards that marketing and it's
all like they have everything this one's
for the woke people that need it exactly
that needs some right books like woke
needs soap too yeah every every company
is supposed to talk at a different
heartstring and it's like the same way
ax uh marketed itself towards us of like
be this alpha male but it stinks all the
women in ax commercials are like you
know super hot skinny none of the women
actually like the smell of ax yeah no
they do
there you go that's not true actually I
talked to this girl in the club and you
being on the side of this table you're
kind of letting me down well this is
this is where we're gonna have some
differences I think always because dude
I dude I kind of smell it on you right
now I got switched at 13.99
well it's 15 I'm not a student sometimes
you believe all women so much you have
to convince women through your male
voice that they're wrong yeah exactly I
don't know themselves you know what I
mean right right because dude I've been
pushing my own opinion I've been with so
many so many tricks dude where like they
always say like oh Nick smells so good
and guess what I'm wearing it [__] ax
your whole life hey when like in Middle
School when it was popping dude I had so
many
fake musk pheromones no I didn't I
wasn't very popular with the ladies in
the Middle School
the skin skin brand fair and lovely fair
is that worth it makes your pigment
lighter it just makes you lighter it
makes you like light-skinned why'd you
only ask me because
I don't know you look like you have some
kind of secret
[Laughter]
future doesn't he
Ard
[Music]
yeah
Nick's the kind of guy that walks
outside with an umbrella in a sunny day
yeah I wore my gardening gloves when I
drive
fair and lovely got under a bunch of
fire like everybody was like everybody's
making a big deal out of it because of
its like whole uh you know divide
because a lot of Filipino people use
that too because like in Filipino
culture you're the more light-skinned
you are the more classier yeah and a lot
of Indian people also were like being
told that same I think it's a common
theme amongst a lot of cultures yeah
yeah totally but better you are the more
high-class you so the funny the funny I
guess like oxymoron and all this is that
like that's also in the same ownership
umbrella as dove that's a crazy company
it's a crazy it's a wild company wow
it's a model though yeah yeah for sure
well think about it too because like you
you look around like you know Black
Rifle coffee yeah like my buddy's one of
the founders of that no way yeah yeah my
buddy Richard Ryan and it's basically
like you know I mean he wouldn't say
this but it's like Republican coffee
right and like but that's and that's
what it is so it's like hey we're
selling coffee yeah but like hey you're
Republican right are you tired of like
take taking it or whatever
let's get there are you tired of this
beta coffee we're gonna try [__]
Black Rifle baby don't drink with the
cucks are drinking drink with America
with 1776 is having
take a look take a look at these look
straight
no that's the bottles that oh dude the
people at Target must be like [__] we
have to rearrange these [__] racks
like how are we gonna fit all these
goddamns are they is that the show you
the different sizes of women it's to
represent yes it's for real it's to
represent the different varying shapes
I've never seen and they're all I've
never seen that in different sizes
different dictions
[Laughter]
meanwhile we get one condom that
stretches all the way up yeah no let's
fight for us
nobody makes them an extra small little
soaps and all that is marketed toward
women yeah like all the all the
purchases are made by 100 yeah
but the funny thing is like to think
that would be like stop glorifying big
dicks that'll be cool
I think out of all of this the main
thing to take away is that when
corporate Brads tweet don't really take
that seriously man have you seen slim
jim everywhere though
but you can't tweet something like uh
you know this whole thing against I know
like this movie is supposed to be really
amazing and again Brandon Frazier did a
really good job
um with making sure that he represented
it well like he really cared about it do
you think Dove is really speaking to
Their audience though yeah 100 I think
they are I like their soap but now I'm
not gonna buy it because this yeah same
yeah dude down with Dove dude in this
movie I haven't seen this movie or even
a trailer but is he like huffing and
puffing all over
is Brandon Frasier like
I think he has oxygen thing on in one of
the scenes does every time he leaves the
house they have to break down the wall
he's got a soldering team put his wall
back on listen to a little bit of what
Brendan Fraser said in an interview
about it it's actually pretty cool what
he said Eddie Murphy did that's just in
the last 20 years yeah anything before
then
it's it's a cutout silhouette of a
costume that's stuffed with uh like
batting and it's normally it's an
athletic actor yeah inside yes the
silhouette of a suit and it was all in
the service of just you know kind of a
mean joke or one note sort of chick that
I think we're better then there are
those who live with this disease and it
was my obligation to to be their voice
was that Adam Sandler yeah that's so
that's interesting doves harping on him
for just not committing enough like like
they want him to be diabetic basically I
agree with Steve so what what is what
are they saying like are they are they
saying like hey that's that's healthy
you need a you need a healthy fat person
to represent a healthy fat person people
should be careful about this like
realistic interpretation [__] because
like you're gonna you're gonna end up
with Brendan Fraser in the whale and
like it's supposed to be a dramatic
scene but then he's like
like farting out of his ass he's like
that's realistic
[__]
wild out there but like how far does it
go are they are they gonna start being
mad that that people are playing like
someone with AIDS in their HIV negative
yeah I would be mad right well where is
the line now are you [__] pissed
Maddie Ziegler playing the girl with uh
was it autism oh right oh yeah there was
that thing Sia directed a movie right
Sia made the movie and the main
character had autism but she had Maddie
Ziegler do it and people were like
Maddie Ziegler doesn't have autism
like she was portraying that character
there's like a whole thing about it I
remember we wanted an autistic person to
do that yeah I know right right um Henry
Cavill can't fly Maybe
um
Greening he he he he had a movie that
came out and I remember doing this girl
there was a scene with a with a a
lesbian lovers making out right yeah
she was like uh we're the uh were the
actors a part of the lgbtq community or
whatever and then like we just asked
that and this was like the second
question
that's there she asked another dumbass
question and then she asked this
question nothing about the [__] film
by the way just some stupid woke [__]
that it's like shut the [__] up and then
like
um yeah basically the moderator kept two
like calling on her and I'm like nobody
else wants to ask call someone who's
[__] gonna happen dude there were
hands bro no they weren't hands it was
weird they were [__] heads and I was
like why did she get to go too [__]
back-to-back questions I think the
moderator is a people pleaser and so he
could sense that she was kind of bugged
and wanted to like yeah she's like she's
in the crowd like this oh he's a king so
he's like ah okay yeah she really wants
to ask a question
um was the lipstick real in that scene
it's like who the [__] cares was the
lipstick animal tested isn't acting the
purpose of it is to act and it's getting
the line's getting real gray it's
getting blurry Line's getting blurry
though I just feel like we just
hopefully it is just a small percentage
of people that actually feel this way
because I think most of the people that
talked about the whale that I talk to
they're like oh dude the movie was great
I don't know anyone that's just about a
fat guy yeah I think in the in the back
of my mind what I'm really hoping is
that when these things happen that news
Publications are like okay we're gonna
take that small percentage that feels
that way and we're gonna piss off the
large percentage because it sells yeah
because I hope that's all it ever will
be Twitter is so different than real
life like all the [__] that I hear
people bitching about on Twitter I've
never heard a real person say ever
you're right you're right yeah that's a
good point yeah out never that's why I
feel like now we're living in
toots War like the online world has its
own sentiment and like culture yeah and
like the real world doesn't like the
physical world
that's probably the best way to look at
it yeah to compartmentalize because it's
like it's not the same like the rules on
the internet obviously aren't the same
as they are in person you know it does
suck when productions for some reason
really think that that's going to get in
the way of their money in the future and
they make adjustments to accommodate
opinions that might not actually be real
yeah but once they do that and they make
zero money on their next movie they're
going to realize oh this is not the way
we I guess I think we are seeing that
happen a professional like Brendan
Fraser who's been in so many movies that
can act and hold like because people
forget like when you make a movie like
you need reliable trustworthy people to
hold up yeah like you can't just get
actors yeah you can't just get some
random guy just because he's 600 pounds
he's never acted before Brendan Fraser
didn't he play like was it George of the
Jungle has like a disability or some
[__] yeah he was a mute yeah but he's
sitting there talking [__] on Eddie
Murphy like wearing a fat suit and
ripping [__] ass yeah like like like
to me it's like
and he did but people like we're like it
wasn't like hey [__] fat people huh [__]
fat people and also too in the era of
that those movies it was such a
different time like obviously nowadays
you can't make a Nutty Professor yeah
exactly like we watched the night
professors today we're like oh yeah some
of these jokes will not fly here and
it's not crazy but it's just like
nowadays it's just a difference but
Eddie's just sitting there going like
man [__] I hate fat people oh yeah
I'm gonna get them good here I'm gonna
get him real good here they [__] him
forever but then Brendan Fraser sounded
like this it's like I don't know dude
it's like I wish people just shut the
[__] up sometimes a little bit a little
bit right because it's just like it's
just very like he's like you know like
they've never been like represented in a
little [__] I'm like well no actually
Eddie Murphy represented the [__] out of
fat people dude like fat people I hadn't
seen fat people that morbidly obese
before Eddie Murphy actually
shoving Blimpy Subs in his face the
whole movie and yeah I have seen fat
people do that actually it's not that
crazy it's not that crazy
[Music]
yeah
thank you